as I wanted to be an investment banker
walk on Wall Street at money out of my
pockets and then now looking at that
it's such an impoverished perspective or
the possibilities of what I can do in my
life it's not that money doesn't matter
it's that it's in service of something
much bigger much better
here at South by Southwest Interactive
some of the digital world's brightest
minds gather to discuss trends that will
guide the tech industry in the year to
come
one of those minds is Ben Rattray
founder and CEO of change org an online
petition site that is attracted 45
million users from across the globe
since launching in 2007 Rattray who is
named one of Time Magazine's most
influential people under 40 says that
the tech industry is reinventing the way
companies run a change he says that will
renew capitalism and bolster the economy
by making corporations more accountable
to their customers and employees reason
TV caught up with Rattray outside the
Austin Convention Center where we asked
if making profit is that odds of having
a social purpose our thesis is one of
the most important vehicles for
advancing social change is business and
if business isn't in the long-term
profitable then it's not going to be
sustainable it's not going to be
scalable but we do passionately believe
in this idea of the short-term economic
returns that people think that drive a
lot of public companies actually
undermine both social good and economic
good in the long term and so what we're
most excited about is companies taking a
long term perspective where there is
that combination of purpose and profit
you know you talk about social good and
I think it's easy for people to get a
little bit cynical about that but you
said something great which is you can't
really regulate good so what is the
incentive them for business to kind of
step in and start policing themselves we
think there are two really important
forces that are happening in society
that are giving companies the incentive
to just behave better behave and their
best selves we say first is massive
consumer mobilization online the
companies that used to do have policies
that were obscure that were it's a
massive degradation of the environment
or something in their supply chain now
the consumers know that it can mobilize
around it they actually change
incentives we see on a regular basis
citizen movements that are calling on
companies to have more ethical supply
chains and it's an example of how
consumers are willing actually to pay in
to support these companies but they
previously haven't known that
information your website changed or
plays a big pivotal role in kind of
organizing people and I find it
interesting because you grew up wanting
to be Gordon Gekko how did you go from
that to find you know a website based on
social
I think that the people that I know that
are most passion about social change in
many cases are those that saw a
different path to themselves when they
were younger it takes really somebody
who saw the possibility of exclusively
focusing on economic returns I wanted to
be an investment banker walk on Wall
Street at money out of my pockets and
then now looking at that it's such an
impoverished perspective of the
possibilities of what I can do in my
life it's not that money doesn't matter
it's that it's in service of something
much bigger much better and I think that
people are happiest when they're part of
meaningful organizations where they feel
like they're making an impact and that's
what we are trying to do a change in
order Rattray doesn't just talk about
meaningful change he's leading it by
being one of the early adopters of
benefit corporation status benefit
corporations also known as beef
corporations our new class has certified
for-profit companies that voluntarily
meet higher standards of accountability
and transparency you know we talked
about in the beginning stages of
founding changes or we decided that the
most effective vehicle for us was not a
company or rather not a nonprofit it was
a company there wasn't sort of an
obvious path for us to demonstrate that
though we were a company we really cared
about social change and so while I
because of my own passions led the
company in that direction it's a lot
more profound I think and pervasive when
you end up having an outside
certification process or you can make a
commitment to this and that's what
happened with big corporation in 2011
and so for us it really enshrined our
beliefs that already existed but allowed
us to deeply embed it within the
organization and make a public
pronouncement and hold ourselves
accountable to it
now we've seen tech companies like yours
doing this do you see this kind of
falling into more mature sectors like
for instance coal or energy do you do
you see this idea spreading yeah so B
corporations almost have a thousand
corporations around the country now
around the world and it's only
accelerating I think what will happen is
people that are early adopters will have
holding gains it's a real opportunity to
gain from a brand perspective trust in
the community and the people that are
not doing it don't feel so much pain
however once it hits a certain critical
mass and you start getting momentum
companies that are not big corporations
will look I think more suspect and see
if you're trying to recruit out of let's
say major universities business schools
and the top talent across the country
because there'll be a critical mass of
companies that are big corporations
we'll be the ones that attract more
talent they will be the ones that get
more success or press coverage and
attention and trust of consumers and so
I think it'll be it'll be long arc and
progressively sort of developing but it
will happen now talking about creating
the social change why is the tech
industry kind of this Ground Zero for
you know not only being profitable like
like Facebook but also having these
policies that promote like social
wellness I think that companies in the
tech sector that are the largest
oftentimes our platforms that empower
other people and power them let's say
through eBay to create their own
business and power through and a
Facebook to connect to others and change
your own empower through their voice and
platforms like ours that rely on
community participation the drive value
because of the participation of everyday
people I think are more subject to the
concerns of those people I think we are
holding be holding more accountable to
those that are contributing to our our
platforms and so that's why I think the
tech companies have a unique sort of
role to play in building businesses
focus on the social impact well Ben
thank you so much for your time thank
you so much for reason TV I'm Alexis
Garcia